invisible mais essentiel déclinée en
différentes disciplines c'était le thème
du premier tedx uv est ce qu un projet
mené par quatre étudiants de l'institut
supérieur de management de l'université
à la base on voulait orienté sur tout ce
qui est mystérieux et en fait on s'est
rendu compte que ce qui était souvent
mystérieuses c'est ce qu'on ne voyait
pas donc l'invisible et donc on s'est
dit c'est vrai que dans le monde qui
nous entoure il ya beaucoup de choses
qui sont essentiels mais qui reste
invisible et c'est une chance unique
d'avoir conférence qui pourrait nous
permettre de connaître ces choses
invisibles
une conférence consacrée à l'innovation
18 minutes pour chacun des cinq
intervenants
une première pour un anniversaire celui
de l'université lu vs qu souffle ses 25
bougies
quand les premiers sont arrivés ici avec
des bancs il y avait des cerveaux
comment tous ces montées les labos de
recherche
on est à la fois très jeune on a on est
toujours on a toujours une taille
humaine qui nous permet et bien de
réagir très rapidement
tout le monde se connaissent assez
important mais 25 ans eh bien on se
projette aussi maintenant vers l'avenir
pour cette année scolaire 2016-2017
l'université versailles saint quentin a
accueilli plus de 18 mille étudiants